he's a recycling evangelist Allah did
not agree in a couple of days he's going
to prison there's no winning when you go
up against Microsoft after a six-year
legal battle with the Department of
Justice
Eric Lundgren is reporting to a Federal
Correctional Facility to begin a
15-month sentence his crime was copying
and selling CDs for restoring the
Windows operating system on broken pcs
so why did Lundgren's crime result in a
jail sentence the answer cuts to the
heart of a major battle going on in the
tech industry today companies are in a
battle to preserve certain aspects of US
copyright law that give them enormous
power over the products we own and in
the process they're trampling on our
First Amendment rights
[Music]
to better understand why Erik Lundgren
posed a major threat to the tech
industry consider the third-party repair
shops that have popped up all over the
country allowing consumers to get their
devices fixed faster and cheaper or a
company like iFixit which runs an online
repair community where people post
repair tutorials on a broad range of
products kyle Wiens is its co-founder I
like to say if you can't fix it you
don't really own it and there was this
kind of dark period in the 80s and 90s
where we have all these new gizmos that
were coming out with VCRs we had
camcorders they all these complex new
gadgets and nobody really knew how to
fix them now that we have the Internet
all this information can get shared
online weaned started the company in his
dorm room 15 years ago when his first
macbook broke
there had been information online on how
to fix it and they had gotten a legal
takedown those from Apple's and that
made me angry so I decided well if they
don't want people to know maybe I want
people to know and so when the head took
the part again took photos put them
online and the rest is history we've
been doing it ever since
in 2016 I fixed it did more than 21
million in sales of tools and repair
kits with 10 million monthly visitors
the company relies on its community of
over 50,000 contributors who offer
repair tips that comprise a growing
library of open source manuals going to
Kansas Pennsylvania we ship all over the
world first
tech company struck back by integrating
special screws and adhesives that aren't
available from third-party sellers then
I fix it had its developer account
banned and app removed from the Apple
Store after it posted a tear down of the
Apple TV in 2015 and for a period of
time
Apple was disabling iPhone 6s when the
company detected work had been done at
independent repair shops the company was
later served with a class-action lawsuit
and reimbursed thousands of affected
consumers but none of these tactics
worked I fix it didn't need the app to
operate their business and the company
figured out a way around those special
screws and adhesives
so tech companies turn to a provision in
u.s. copyright law section 1201 of the
Digital Millennium Copyright Act known
as the DMCA which makes it illegal to
break digital locks protecting
copyrighted work the laws intent was to
protect creative content like movies
music and software from being stolen and
copied and as software increasingly
replaces Hardware under the hoods of our
tech devices this appealed to copyright
law had its desired effect shifting the
balance of power over the stuff you buy
Eric Lundgren was just a few weeks away
from going to prison the day we spoke
with him one man's trash is another
man's treasure right well this is the
world's trash and it's my treasure
before Lunger landed in prison he spent
his days running a company in Los
Angeles that recycles about 40 million
pounds of e-waste annually he's been
passionate about the field since he was
a teenager I grew up in a very small
town and so I just said well I'll be a
recycler by 18 I was doing it for
American Airlines for coca-cola it just
blew up very fast all of this is you
know keyboards and mice and power cords
and I mean a power cord it's it's a cord
it can be used again and again and again
so if I get in truckloads of brand-new
power cords we're gonna put them with
something new and be able to use them
when he was 19
Lundgren relocated to Shenzhen a city in
China's Guangdong province that became
known as the Silicon Valley of hardware
in 2011 he was basically working to
source generic parts for electronics and
then finding brokers in the United
States and basically working as a
middleman there that's Jake Swearengen
tech writer for New York magazine a
broker named Bob wolf approached him he
had already worked with Bob wolf in the
past Bob wolf would provide what's
called a Dell OAM which is original
equipment manufacturer a Dell om
restorer CD and then Lundgren would take
it to a duplicate shop in China and get
tens of thousands of copies made which
then Bob wolf would use as a broker and
sell to PC refurbishers here in the
United States when Lundgren took this
Dell om restore CD to the duplicate shop
in China they didn't just do
locate the software on there they
duplicated everything about the CD so
that includes the labeling on it so the
Dell logo the Microsoft logo everything
about it
they just duplicated the whole thing
wholesale then in 2012 one shipment got
flagged by customs wolf is approached by
the feds participates in a sting
operation targeting Lundgren and then
ultimately the feds raid Lundgren's
house in florida and both he and wolf
are eventually indicted on about 21
counts that range from conspiracy to
distribute counterfeit goods to wire
fraud and a whole host of other charges
[Music]
so the government's case was that longer
than Wolf's were attempting to create a
large-scale counterfeiting enterprise
Lungren pled guilty to conspiracy to
traffic in counterfeit goods and
criminal copyright infringement and
there's no doubt that he's guilty of
wrongdoing emails sent by Lunger and
reveal that he even pressured Wolff to
sell batches of CDs that came out
slightly defective showing his eagerness
to make some money off this
counterfeited merchandise but what's
less clear is the impact his actions had
on Microsoft one of the real problems in
this case that I feel like neither side
was really able to fully resolve is that
there is no real market for a dell OAM
restore CD and the reason for this is is
that when you buy a dell you get this
restore CD for free if you lose it at
any point you can download the software
off the internet for free it doesn't
look like he really hurt anyone very
seriously and yet they're gonna
basically put him in a cage for 15
months Tom W Bell is a law professor at
Chapman University specializing in
intellectual property and copyright
Microsoft may be firm on the law but we
can question whether you know their
motives are really about protecting the
software those motives are all about
controlling software through copyright
law what tech companies are finding is
their most powerful weapon against
third-party repair companies like I fix
it
ever since 1790 the terms of copyright
have gotten longer the rights protected
have gotten more and more broad the
sanctions against infringing have gotten
more and more punitive all the founders
cared about were books maps and charts
they knew about music and sculpture and
paintings and architecture they didn't
think it needed copyright entered the
20th century for adults there's only one
hide item the VCR it's an invention that
some say is changing the whole idea of
television movie studios said this
violated the copyright laws what you
start seeing was the music industry in
Hollywood really aggressively moving
forward on the idea that copyright
infringement should become a criminal
issue and not purely a civil one and
more particularly that people that were
infringing on a large-scale basis and
serve time in jail and copyright law was
written so broadly it applied to
software to copyright law doesn't
distinguish if you have a lot of
copyrights in music and you go and ask
for stronger
copyrights many of the provisions you'd
have change in your favor like the term
of copyright gonna benefit everybody who
has a copyright then as the 2000s rolled
along software was suddenly everywhere
now we are surrounded in copyrighted we
are immersed in copyrighted content so
that means tractors and cards it means
your smartphone it means increasingly
the refrigerators and washing machines
that people have in their homes KITT
Walsh is an attorney with the Electronic
Frontier Foundation also known as EF F
she says that software's ubiquity has
changed the meaning of copyright law
there's a lingering hook that the seller
has in your property that they are
arguing gives them really broad powers
to dictate how you use that property
going forward you're not even allowed to
look at what's in there we sold you this
but you're not allowed to know how it
actually works or what it's actually
doing because that's our copyrighted
code you're not allowed to look at it
and that's presented some unintended
consequences for security researchers
software that's deployed in cars
tractors other important devices has
these controls on it which is a good
thing for a security measure the problem
is when you the owner don't have the the
keys or the permission to go in and open
it up so this interferes with not just
repair but also security research safety
research like the folks who did crash
test dummies EF F is pushing for
copyright reform on First Amendment
grounds code is a form of speech and
courts have grappled with that because
code also feels a lot like a tool they
say based on that functionality it's not
going to be as protected as other forms
of speech even though we have case law
that says if you publish instructions if
you publish a cookbook if you publish
even instructions that are dangerous to
the reader then that's still speech
while EF F is challenging copyright
protections in court right to repair
advocates are pushing for legislation at
the state and federal level I was
testifying in front of the Copyright
Office say hey we need the ability to
repair game consoles in a cost-effective
manner and we had the Entertainment
Software Association opposing us saying
know if people can repair their game
console
it will enable rampant piracy so we're
literally fighting an army of suits it
feels like the matrix sometimes where
there's a new suit that appears from
around the corner every step of the way
we need to actually repeal section 1201
of the Copyright Act it's not doing
anybody any good and we also need to
these state-level right to repair laws
where you have states across the country
that are saying hey big manufacturer if
you're going to sell product in our
state you need to support our local
repair industry you can't cut them out
of the mix you can't monopolize service
there are at least 18 states considering
fair repair bills which are modeled off
the 2012 automotive rights repair law in
Massachusetts which led to a national
agreement with the auto industry to
allow independent repair shops to work
on cars what we want this competition in
the marketplace we want the free market
we want the independent repair shop
shouldn't have an advantage over the
apple store they should they should just
be able to compete on an equal footing
for me ownership is the ability to
understand how something works the
ability to not be trapped in some
ecosystem be dependent on somebody else
I'd like to be able to be self-reliant
to be able to if I have something go
wrong the understand it enough to be
able to fix it
that's what Lungren says he was trying
to do when copyright is criminalized
it's not just making a criminal out of
this Lungren fellow but you can very
plausibly you sit down and examine what
we do every day forwarding emails
posting stuff on Facebook watching an
unauthorized copy of a movie on YouTube
that all of us are probably many times a
day now violating copyright law and
probably some of us you know should
worry about criminal law who owns the
products that you buy you do and you
need to be able to repair those and use
those and give those away and let other
people benefit from whatever it is that
you rightfully own if I have to go to
prison and it's going to raise awareness
I'm happy to go I just want to be able
to get people to become aware and to be
able to have the right to repair what
they legally own
you